Uh stephen what the hell are we wearing i don't
know she said i needed a suit yeah the ceremonial
armor from conscious temple not psycho colonel
sanders
Welcome back everyone this will be my
full marvel moon knight episode 2 video there are
a whole bunch of easter eggs to break down so if
you're brand new to the channel i'm doing videos
for all the episodes be sure to subscribe to get
everything we're doing a giveaway for disney plus
memberships too all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and just leave your favorite moment
from the episode on the video and careful for
spoilers if you have not seen moon knight episode
2 yet we'll just start at the beginning and talk
about wtf moments and easter eggs as we go along
starting with the episode title it was called
summon the suit which is a reference to layla
yelling at him in stephen grant form to summon
the moon knight costume after she starts to learn
what's going on with steven grant not totally
believing what's going on yet she'll eventually
learn more about the multiple personalities soon
and it's a funny reference to him being in
steven grant form when he actually makes the
change summoning the suit kind of unconsciously as
he falls out the window but it winds up being the
mr night suit from the comics with the actual suit
and tie because he's still in steven grant form
and the way they explain it on the tv show the way
they're doing this is that they're saying that the
form that the suit takes is actually based on the
way you think so when he's in full traditional
moon knight form he's in marc spector form but
because steven grant's mind works so differently
when he summons a suit it's based on what
stephen grant is thinking his suit looks like
the difference in the comics is that when he takes
the mr knight persona he's still in marc spector
form he's still moon knight but it's when he's
working with the police being the world's greatest
detective form of moon knight typically in the
comics when he's in mr night form wearing the
suit and someone attacks him or gets into a big
fight he would just switch back into the normal
moon knight costume but the way they doing on
the tv show he still has access to moon knight's
powers and his weapons like he pulls the poles
out of his back when he's in steven grant form not
totally sure what's going on the actual opening
scene is then picking up right after the events
of him beating up the jackals in marc spector moon
knight form inside his apartment in stephen grant
form after another time jump has gone by just like
we've seen in the previous episode although this
time because he remembers everything that happened
he knows about marc spector now inside his head
he tries to contact him again in the mirror when
the security guard calls him scotty by a different
name that's meant to be another reference to all
the different identities in the comics none of
them was named scotty but it's just a reference to
him not understanding who he's speaking to at any
given moment which is something very common in
the comics like are you talking to steven grant
are you talking to marc spector who knows the
way they explain it later too is that when he's
running from the jackal the reason why the camera
glitches and you can't see the jackal is because
normal people who aren't avatars of gods of this
pantheon the enid can't see the creations that
come from their pocket dimension like they show
layla watching the jackal fight but it looks
like it's invisible to her most of you probably
understand the reason why there's no security cam
footage of him in moon knight marc spector form
wearing the costume is because it's really really
illegal to videotape people inside the bathrooms
for very obvious reasons when he's talking to the
security chief after the fact about how they're
not going to file charges there's all kinds of
references to his different personalities he's
sitting between two different lamps a reference
to both marc spector and steven grant the security
chief also reveals that he's probably part of this
cult that arthur harrow leads that's what the
pamphlet is about that he slides out to him
just kind of implying that the security guard all
these other regular members of society are part
of this in some way they've kind of infiltrated
all aspects of life kind of like a hail hydra
type of twist like we are amongst you all over the
place and you don't realize it they also reference
this when the police come to investigate him too
for the quote-unquote missing item that he stole
the security chief also tries to get the scarab
back from him although he's kind of nice in the
way that he talks about it is still a little
bit sinister like are you sure he didn't steal
anything from the museum talking about the scarab
but then it's revealed marc spector hit it back
in his locker so obviously he doesn't have it on
him here then causing the security chief to point
to his name tags just saying like okay leave that
here just another reference to him embracing the
marc spector personality more during this episode
even though they are still kind of fighting each
other inside his head as he leaves it shows marc
spector staring back at him in the reflection on
the desk pretty much any time he passes by any
kind of reflective surface in the episode you
always see one of the different personalities it's
not really until the end of the episode though
that they switched things up and it's marc spector
in the body speaking to stephen grant inside the
reflection he talks to that same street performer
again dressed in gold and he actually looks at
him when he tries to hug him so i'm keep wondering
if this character is going to turn into something
bigger in later episodes he eventually finds marc
spector's storage locker the facility belongs to
when he talks to the security guard he says that
it's number 43 that's a reference to werewolf by
night number 43 which was the last issue of the
werewolf by night comic who's supposed to have
some sort of appearance at the end of this series
setting up his big halloween special later this
year the moon knight character debuted for the
first time in a werewolf by night story i didn't
try scanning the qr code on the locker here with
my phone so if anyone was able to actually get any
new easter eggs from this qr code post them
in the comments below sometimes marvel will
do things like that just like add little qr
easter eggs in the background we've seen most
of the footage in the storage locker and all the
trailers so far it's all of marc spector's stuff
as a mercenary all of his weapons his spare gear
his spare passports the whole idea is that before
he died and became conscious avatar he had been
a mercenary when he pulls out the united states
passport though marc spector's birthday on it is
the exact same day as oscar isaac's birthday in
real life but the year 1987 is a reference to the
year that marvel put moon knight on the west coast
avengers team it's also meant to be a reference to
oscar isaac's moon knight character crossing over
with avengers 5 in the next avengers team also
a lot of the characters they've been introducing
in marvel phase 4 like the brand new ones like
shengshi for instance are coming from the west
coast and a lot of the marvel phase 4 series are
referencing west coast avengers easter eggs also
very important detail here too zoom in enhanced
united states passports get renewed every 10 years
this is due for renewal december 2028 meaning
that he got this one after the snap in avengers
infinity war meaning that marc spector survived
the snap for those of you that are wondering
steven grant starts pawing through all of his
stuff learning about the missions to egypt
some of the recent history in his life the scarab
beetle the reason why it animates and flies around
is because it's meant to work like a supernatural
god-tier compass leading them to amit's physical
remains so the whole idea is that arthur harrow
wants to bring her physically into the mcu she's
currently trapped in this other dimension with
khanshu and the rest of his pantheon they're not
really able to physically change and interact with
the mcu that much until they physically enter it
themselves and the way that arthur harrow plans
to do that to bring her into the mcu again is
to find her physical remains like the bones of her
physical body and then bring her back through some
ceremony using those the thing is is you could
actually do the exact same thing with khonshu
you could physically bring kancho into the mcu if
you were able to find his bones then marc spector
shows up and we get to see the personalities
arguing with each other which is a big thing from
the comics this happens all the time in the comics
and it happens many times throughout the episode
too with both of them yelling at each other one of
the big arcs during the series is them reconciling
with each other and recognizing that each of
them need each of the personalities to survive
he also makes a joke about marc spector being
super handsome even though they are literally
the same person marc spector also talks about
moon knight in the god khonshu out loud for the
first time of course it takes steven grant seeing
khonshu himself to start believing it but he still
doesn't totally believe until later in the episode
when he actually sees the suit manifest around him
when he says they protect the vulnerable and
deliver conscious justice to those who hurt them
it's a reference to him being called the fist of
khonshu in the comics which arthur harrow mentions
later in the episode after he reveals that he
used to be khonshu's previous avatar before marc
spector he keeps talking about the vengeance of
khonshu the fist of khonshu it's a reference to
khonshu being the mcu god of vengeance in addition
to him being the egyptian god of the moon after
khonshu tries to show up and tell him what's what
he runs away again this time running straight into
layla who's trying to find his cell phone signal
you do see stuff start to move around when kancho
gets really pissed and they kind of clarify this
later in the episode is another example of his
limited ability to interact with the physical mcu
while he's trapped in some other dimension the
whole idea with layla as they explain is that she
doesn't really know anything about what's going
on with steven grant yet but she did know that he
died and became moon knight the avatar of khonshu
because she keeps telling him through the
episode to summon the suit so to speak
when they referenced him disappearing two months
ago and sending her divorce papers trying to keep
her safe by pushing her away it sounds like
what happened is they got into a fight with
arthur harrow's men and that's how he died but
then because of what kanchi was doing to his
mind trying to take over his body physically it
caused him to lose control between the different
personalities and that's why the stephen grant
persona was able to get out but also on the side
marc spector has been trying to not contact layla
and hide from her just to protect her from khonshu
because as we learn if something happens to marc
spector he dies a second time or he decides to
sever his deal with khonshu like arthur harrow did
being his former avatar then khonshu has already
selected layla as his next potential avatar layla
is a brand new character that they created for the
series but she's meant to be a combination of a
couple of characters from classic moon knight's
backstory in the series she's already explained
to be marc spector's wife like she's been his wife
for a while now i believe she's meant to be just a
combination of the marlene love interest character
and her father who's an archaeologist that's why
when she's talking to steven grant she understands
the book's egyptian hieroglyphics in the comics
marc spector wound up dying protecting marlene
and her father from the mercenary bushmen trying
to pilfer the ruins of conscious tomb as he lay
dead at the feet of the statue khonshu then used
that opportunity to make him his avatar later in
the comics they also explained that khonshu had
been targeting marc spector his entire life and
just kind of waiting for the right opportunity
they referenced that later in the episode too
when they talk about his history of mental health
in how he always had this alternate personality
that he kept buried within him but now it's a
problem because of what happened with khonshu
and they'll probably say that he initially died
the first time becoming conscious avatar when he
was fighting arthur harrow's men she yells about
his bad english accent which is just a reference
to the audience yelling it oscarized its bad
english accent remember it's meant to be fake
like it's a creation of his mind as steven goes
back and forth with layla she tries to figure out
what's going on marc spector keeps yelling at him
in all the different reflections around the room
about not telling her what's going on to protect
her he also tells her that this is his mother's
flat the person that he keeps calling who seemed
like she was fake but then layla says oh you made
up with your mother so apparently marc spector
had problems with his real-life mother but i think
part of the idea is that the number that stephen
keeps calling is actually something that marc
spector set up so all the messages might have
been actually going to marc spector instead
the whole thing with the french poem that he
believes is his favorite but is actually layla's
favorite is probably just his memories as marc
spector bleeding into steven grant's memories
and steven grant just falsely believing that
it was his favorite no no no it was my favorite
and i think part of the idea with her talking
about all this egyptian history is that there are
things that stephen grant will have learned that
marc spector doesn't know and that'll be part of
the reason why they keep both of the personalities
around like why wouldn't you just try to get rid
of the other one in the comics that's because each
has their own specific skills and together they
form a much more capable superhero than he would
otherwise be just using one of the personalities
when the police who are working for arthur harrow
come to investigate him to take the scarab back
it shows his apartment number number 502 that's
a reference to avengers 502 which was during the
avengers disassembled air in the comics and some
of the things that were happening in the comics
are actually happening in the mcu right now as we
speak during the events of doctor strange too like
during a lot of the trailer videos you see scarlet
witch just going completely off the rails during
that avengers disassembled era doctor strange
was going around believing that something bad had
happened to magic and bad things were at play that
was a reference to what scarlet witch was doing
going off the rails during that era which she is
now doing inside the mcu marvel phase 4 movies
i also just did a video about why doctor strange
is allowing all this crazy stuff with the mcu gods
to take place just because there's so much going
on in the mcu right now so i'll link that below
in the description because it's kind of his job to
protect this reality from those kinds of threats
all the backstory that these police pull up on
him is a reference to his comic book backstory
he was a mercenary initially in the comics the
dig site was where the statue of khonshu was
the avatar of khonshu where he made the deal
it sounds like what happened is is the arthur
harrow's men killed all these archaeologists
that were at the dig site where he wound up
dying becoming the avatar of khonshu but they just
blamed all the des on marc spector after the fact
you then see their tattoos of the scales
confirming that they're part of this cult that
arthur harrow leads for amid they take him to an
area of london that their group controls it's just
another very hail hydra type of moment like all
types of people from society belong to our group
were secretly among you and you don't realize
it arthur harrow then learns the truth about
what's going on with his multiple personalities
and explains to him the truth of the matter the
reason why all these weird things are happening
to you the reason why you can hear khonshu and
why i know all about him all of his secrets but
i can't hear him or see him anymore is because
i arthur harrow used to be his avatar he doesn't
literally explain it but he kind of implies why
he decided to stop being khonshu's avatar and
become the first avatar of ammit all the stuff
that he tells steven grant about khonshu being
this petulant god acting like a child being
banished by the other gods being a liar never
letting his body go just having one more mission
at all times like is always going to be one more
mission that's all true khonshu is not a nice
god issues of the gods that khonshu is fighting
against during this ammit for example are way
worse so it's very much a devil you know kind of
situation like okay khonshu is bad but it gives
me all these powers and i can be a good superhero
with them and defeat all these even worse people
it's kind of like becoming ghost writer in the
mcu and why he works so well on this midnight
suns type of team this darker mcu supernatural
team up because most of their patron saints or
where they get their powers from are very shady
sources but they try to use those powers for good
when he references khonshu picking him as his
avatar because his mind was broken or easy to
break that's another call back to his origin in
the comics which they referenced later in the
episode too like i always kept a barrier between
us but now because of khonshu controlling our
body that barrier has weakened and that's why
he keeps switching so much between different
personalities when he says that stephen doesn't
have to do everything that khonshu asks him to
that's another reference to the comics where a lot
of times marc spector will have to fight khonshu
when he asks him to do shady things that put
him at odds with the other avengers characters
when he references them learning other languages
and starts speaking mandarin chinese i think
that's meant to be another slight connection
to what happened during the shangshi movie
with those characters when arthur harrow starts
ragging more on khonshu calling him this really
petulant god and getting banished by the other
gods i also think a good example to make would
be like early thor in the mcu like thor god of
thunder is one of the lesser gods in the mcu
but for a while odin thought that he was really
irresponsible and banished him to earth the same
kind of thing has happened between khonshu and
the other gods that are part of his pantheon
eventually khonshu will probably help moon knight
defeat amit and the other gods will re-accept him
back into their fold you get a little bit of a
tutorial between the differences of khonshu and
amit like they're both gods of vengeance in the
mcu but ammit wants to go full minority report
killing everyone who will do evil and they turn
into this whole big thing about wow you support
a group where people love killing children you
want to go around killing a bunch of children
just to remind you how much worse their group is
than what khonshu might do i've already explained
his plan to bring amit physically into the mcu
from this other dimension like he's gonna find her
remains using that god tier compass the scarab
perform a ceremony and then sort of reinfuse
her earthly remains with her spirit to make a
star wars reference is sort of like a reverse
force ghost situation if you could somehow stuff a
force ghost back into the bones of the former jedi
master that they used to be layla shows up to help
him and we actually get to see what it looks like
when arthur harrow is using the artifacts of ammit
as her avatar to bring the jackals into this world
eventually enough people start yelling in his
ear that stephen grant gets pushed out the window
unconsciously winds up changing into the suit
but like i explained the reason why it becomes
the mr knight version of the suit is because he's
still on steven grant form and the way they're
explaining in the mcu is a little bit different
from the comics and they're just saying that it's
because the way stephen grant's mine thinks this
is what a suit is supposed to look like as opposed
to marc spector who knows what the actual
moon knight costume is supposed to look like
but for the most part they both have access to
weapons they both have the exact same powers
they have this funny moment where he talks to
himself as marc spector like what are we wearing
we look like colonel sanders making a kentucky
fried chicken reference i've already explained
why the other regular characters from the mcu
can't see these creations of the gods why they
look invisible when he gets pushed up against the
bus you see a big grc ad which is a reference to
falcon and winter soldier and other current stuff
during marvel phase four the grc is the global
repatriation committee and they're sort of like
the sinister group in the mcu that's formed by
all the world governments after the blip to send
all the people who weren't snapped back to the
countries that they originally came from this
is also the second time that he's consciously
switched between different personalities giving
marc spector control of the body it's just more
of the show deepening the connection between the
different personalities in the comics this is a
very common thing with the different personalities
actually working with each other they also explain
what happens to things that come from this pocket
dimension from the gods when he kills something
from their reality it just fades into nothingness
they explained the scare fell off of him during
the fight arthur harrow got it the reason why this
is meant to be super creepy scene is because he
isn't killing the homeless man because he hates
homeless people he's like okay it's totally fine
that you're homeless he winds up sucking his soul
because apparently the person did something bad
in his past or he will do something bad in most of
this last part of the episode it's just clarifying
some of the details and what's been going on in
his life this whole time where the stephen grant
persona came from and why marc spector has been
doing things this way since becoming moon knight
when he says he's been quote unquote doing this
for a long time it's more of a reference to his
multiple personalities having secretly been a
thing for most of his life and previously he just
been keeping them completely separate with this
big mental barrier that he directed when he says
the barrier was weakened when he lost control
of his body and someone else started taking
control of it he's talking about khonshu himself
because khonshu then literally shows up and says
whose body do you think this is it's my body he
reiterates that if marc spector dies or something
happens to him or they end their agreement he will
go after layla as his next avatar and he's trying
to do everything he can to protect layla like i
said this is the first time we've also seen marc
spector being the one in the real world talking to
steven grant in his head but using the reflection
of the mirror which is why he stomps on it later
because he just wants to get him to go away
then at the end of the episode there's another
time jump as he wakes up in egypt like the show
is going back to egypt because arthur harrow is
looking for ammit's remains which would be in
egypt and he has the scarab but during episode 3
obviously we'll learn more about his backstory his
adventures with layla the event that caused him to
become moonai to make the bargain with konshu and
more of what's going to be happening in present
day with amit trying to come back into the mcu
also all the exposition at the end of the episode
happening at this triangle pyramid monument is
another reference to the history on the show and
taking things back to egypt because they literally
go back to egypt next but if you spotted any other
easter eggs in the episode that i didn't mention
in the video just write them below in the comments
in my new doctor strange 2 trailer video we'll
post next and then i'll post more moon knight
bonus videos my full moon knight episode 3 video
will post next week just like normal everyone
click here for my new doctor strange trailer
video i'll update the link as soon as i post it
and click here for all my moon knight episode
videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!